please buy my album I really need to
work on it a lot and now that it's done
I'll play the track that it's got and
I'm not just gonna let them I'm gonna
play a medley of along because there are
a lot 17 tracks and you may have forgot
I'm gonna sing them all right now and
that's not the most exciting part I'll
also show you shark eye Jones's art it's
on the back of the poster and now let's
start I don't know what you mean when
you say please explain what is the FDP
I don't know when you say please explain
what is the FTP
yo this is in Hogwarts this is a
concrete box and the pictures on the
wall are never gonna talk in the deep
sea anglerfish love the reason to be
happy but she has the freaking idea what
else to be I know that you don't think I
know that I don't wanna know I don't
know what you think of it think you know
I don't look make lost her furry skirt
she said it was stolen the shoe salesman
wanted to help cos he had so much solo
cheese cuz it cos he was a girl
homicidal squirrel yes cuz he could do
the girl homicidal squirrel protons and
neutrons the electron clouds scattered
around she was the first girl who ever
made me follow I just took too long to
ask to the freakin you bomb
well there's a lot of cool things about
the County Fair but the demolition derby
is why I'm there
and if fatherhood is the most important
job by far than my nan I know who the
fathers on the founding fathers are why
don't I know the fathers of the founding
fathers I have a complicated
relationship with the distal portion of
my large intestine also known as to cool
and I started field Conners viddy 123
and then that pain got worse worse every
day and the days turn into weeks you
don't love because I'm not Edward Cullen
I can wear sparkly makeup and act all
brave and soul in this box you every
television crime show from CSI to
Columbo everyone thinks of Jesus on the
eve of Christmas but not everything's to
put him on their list so Jesus gets
nothing for Christmas this is a song for
all the vegetables that look like
penises
there's no place that I'd rather be I
live in here with my
making videos happily on nerdfighteria
vomit fight area
I'm nerd factory yeah
[Music]
so I guess it all makes sense that the
yeah guess it all makes sense at the end
John I've always been proud of you in
the creative things that you've done it
means so much to me to know that you get
what I'm doing and that you like it
thank you so much for that and as a
special thank you to everyone who
pre-orders this machine phones noobs we
are including a signed guitar pick in
every single pre-order package so if you
want to get one those you gotta buy the
album now and while you're at dftba.com
you out on check out some of the other
great stuff we've got like my first
album so jokes my live album Molly
Lewis's new album and dr. noises new
album which are both only six dollars I
really appreciate everyone supporting
YouTube musicians and I really think
that all nerdfighters will really enjoy
this album so thank you all so much and
I'm out
[Music]